casi 40 años han tenido que pasar para
que un Papa vuelva a Kim shasa la
capital de la República democrática del
Congo Y eso que es el país de mayor
presencia Católica Romana en África
alrededor del 40% de la población de 96
millones de habitantes practica esta fe
y ahora espera un con ganas la visita
del Papa Francisco
a Dios por la llegada del Papa aquí como
saben nuestro país se enfrenta
situaciones relacionadas con la guerra
no hay paz cuando venga aquí traerá Paz
a nuestro país Bienvenido al papa
la guerra ha asolado la República
democrática del Congo durante décadas
con más de 120 grupos armados y milicias
de autodefensa en lucha por la tierra y
el poder el país tiene 6 millones de
desplazados internos como Maggie Luis
quien hace 10 años Tuvo que salir del
este del país por la violencia y ahora
podrá reunirse con el papa camana
poder de decirles a los que toman
decisiones y a las multinacionales que
el Congo no es un lugar de guerra
el papa visitará Yuba la capital de
Sudán del sur donde los preparativos y
la expectación también avanzan
Ojalá la gracia de Dios realmente se
arraigue en este país y pueda traer paz
y Justicia a todos y cada uno de los
ciudadanos de nuestro querido ciudadano
del sur
el Papa Francisco visita así dos países
africanos afectados por los conflictos y
el hambre donde la iglesia ha sido un
actor clave en temas de salud sistemas
educativos y en la construcción de paz y
democracia